Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones a couple
of days early. We are off on Thursday and
Friday for Thanksgiving. So we are taking
calls today. We take calls via discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord and
we're working through some technical
issues. And let's see if we can do it. Let's
go first to Toby from North Carolina. Toby,
if you can hear me and if you're unmuted,
let me know what's on your mind today.
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Hi. So recently with the shooting in
Colorado, at what point do you think we should
start holding people accountable for the hateful
rhetoric surrounding gay people and trans people
and other marginalized groups? Because it
seems like you could draw a pretty direct
line between violence and these people's rhetoric.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, morally speaking, I think
it's pretty clear that there is already what we
might call responsibility. And in fact, we did
a segment earlier about how they're going pretty
quickly to the victim blaming and saying, listen,
these groomers should expect what's going on
because of gender affirming care and so on and so
forth. So, morally speaking, we're already there.
Legally speaking, we're really kind of talking
about a type of stochastic terrorism. And it we've
talked before about how it is really difficult to
hold people legally responsible. When you have
an audience of 5 million and you target some
individual or a group and then one person goes and
does something, I'm not saying anyone specifically
said go and do this at this particular place,
but when someone goes and does something, legally
speaking, you're not really going to be able to
hold them accountable based on current law. And
I don't even know exactly what a better law would
look like. I'm just not weighing in, but I just
don't think you're really going to be able to.
Speaker 3: All right. That's all I got. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Toby from North Carolina,
thank you very much. Appreciate hearing from you.